m
mobilisation générale pour la 18e
édition du challenge des créateurs
d'entreprise
c'est au village corail qu'a lieu le
speed casting première étape d'un rendez
vous attendu pour ses créateurs mais
déjà c'est un défi ouais c'est de voir
un prêt par la suite qu'est ce que ça
donne il vient présenter mes produits
puis penser c'est une façon pour moi tu
es à commettre la mort de créer du
contact et là c'est une bonne vitrine
aussi je pensais pouvoir attirer tout le
monde sollicité donner envie aux gens
justement de faire deux tiers des
meubles pendant tout ce qui est
recyclable faire connaître mes produits
la marqueterie ce n'est pas connu à la
réunion
par groupes de dix les candidats ont
défilé devant les membres du réseau pour
un chance un regroupement d'associations
et d'institutions qui ont pour objectif
la réussite du créateur d'entreprise
je vais leur demander de se présenter et
puis on va leur poser quelques questions
et on a accès à leur fiche technique et
par rapport à la fiche technique donc on
fera la notation en création
prêt-à-porter et couture
mais c'est les mac je suis reconnue
handicapée après deux opérations dernier
discale est ce que je veux dire par là
c'est pas qu'on pleure sur moi c'est
justement tu es un modèle pour mon
activité c
joris marveaux nice s'impose à volailles
ça permettra laury's et le parcours des
candidats et ça permet aussi de faire
connaître de les faire connaître donc et
puis ça permet de se rencontrer entre
eux donc les les candidats son encontre
entre eux et rencontres les partenaires
qui ne visualise pas forcément sur les
territoires
l'homo jean-david douze candidats ont
été sélectionnés sur la centaine de
dossiers incité ses créateurs à ce l'on
sait a du sens beaucoup de dynamisme
beaucoup de 2,2 de nouveautés beaucoup
d'eux d'avoir envie de de grandir de
rester là ce département en charge de
l'insertion et o2 les micro entreprises
qui sont là aujourd'hui sont des
personnes qui ont eu un parcours
d'insertion bénéficiaires du rsa
recherche d'emploi depuis des nombreuses
années et qui ont créé leur emploi
plusieurs reportages seront réalisées et
diffusées sur antenne réunion
un coup de pouce en termes de
communication pour ses créateurs qui
dynamise le tissu économique local